[Music]
all right we are back
jack
what's up sarah and banger main you're
not jack i was just trying to rhyme
because i want to be a rapper but i'm
not i just made this whole thing a mess
how are you
okay how are you i'm good what's going
on
well thanks for taking my call i've got
kind of a dilemma
bring it on
my uh
letter
by her younger siblings
okay go back and do that again i just
you cut out
um my pre-teen daughter
recently outed to me by her younger
siblings as being bisexual okay
she doesn't want to talk about it
and she has made me promise not to tell
her dad oh okay
yeah so i'm i'm trying to figure out how
do i balance your daughter's trust
versus being honest with my husband in
our marriage
[Laughter]
what what are you have you ever listened
to this show before
uh many times yes okay so what number
one thank you there's only about 11 of
us left and so i'm grateful
um what do you think
that you should do
um i i don't know
i've been just kind of talking to her
trying to
i'm trying to convince her to talk to
her dad
because i don't think that he's going to
freak out about it he's very accepting
um i want him to be able to help support
her and
i
i believe in honesty between us so
i i just don't want to do it against her
wishes and have her not trust me
gotcha okay
so
a couple of super important moments here
and is she your oldest
yeah awesome so you have a chance to
screw this up and you'll never get it
back okay so you gotta i'm just what i'm
worried about i'm totally kidding
um totally totally kidding so
but this is a really neat moment in your
family's history especially in your
relationship with her and so
hold two things
in uh one and one hand and one on the
other okay
first thing is
you are modeling
what a good marriage looks like
so that's a meta that's something that's
gonna pay dividends down the road and we
all know secrets destroy marriages
yes and
you're modeling how you best love
somebody
who's
going through some sort of anything
and so i think it's really important
that you sit down with her and say i
love you
and
i do not keep
secrets in my marriage
so
what if
i told dad my husband
let's call him bill i'm gonna tell bill
that you came to me with um
a really big thing that i found out
about it and it was big and it's on your
heart and that we are talking about it
together and that you are uncomfortable
talking to him
but one day we'll have that conversation
together
and that's that's a middle ground
letting her know i'm gonna tell him here
is one way we could do it or
i will tell him everything but i'll let
him know that you don't want to talk
about it yet
um and i will let you have that
conversation with with him on your terms
when you're ready and if you can hear my
language there it's a it's gonna happen
it doesn't have to be right now but i'm
not gonna hold secrets from my husband
does that make sense
it does
so there's some discomfort there i get
a
how old is she
almost 13. okay
your 13 year old is
doesn't get a vote how about that
right in how your marriage is going to
go and which things you are and aren't
going to tell it feels like you're
violating her trust you're not
the other side of this is
this is an entry
this is a testing moment for how are you
gonna handle my heart and this you'll
have a hundred of these or a thousand
not a thousand but you'll have a bunch
of these
before y'all's relationship is over
someday right when you're an old old old
200 year old grandma
um
the other hand here is you're holding is
how are you going to handle my heart
when i tell you something hard and
that's when there's less info less
trying to convince less data and more
how are we feeling today tell me what's
on your heart and mind what's going on
it does
i think one of the biggest things she's
ever confided in me she's not
people
and honestly
you're cutting out a little bit say that
again so this is the biggest thing she's
ever combined in you
yeah she's not one to confide in people
she thinks to herself okay
you know this being something that now i
have
in my keeping
if i start telling
that
this would be something where she's not
going to confide in me in the future
and i think
so let's look at this a different way
um so
you're you're breaking up a little bit
so but i heard it and i want to make
sure that the listener everybody's
hearing this
your daughter doesn't confide in a lot
of people she keeps things very private
and she has mult who knows the the
reasons she's a 13 14 year old
um
young woman
but she keeps things private
in her head the worst case scenario is
that people find out these things
whatever these things happen to be
and then she's ostracized she's mocked
she's told she's dumb her feelings don't
matter all that stuff
a great gift for her can be to find out
a
i know everything about you
and i still love you
because in her head love is a
performance
love is a tightrope she's trying to walk
about what she feels like she's feeling
whatever pressure she's
receiving from the outside world and
then trying to bring home and then also
perform as your daughter or your
husband's daughter
or as the oldest kid fill in the blank
a gift for her and this is gentle
can be no i hear you
and you don't shock me
i hear you and i love you
i hear you and i want to learn more
about you
because at the end of the day all of us
really want two things
to be fully known and still loved
and for a kid who keeps things private
who keeps things held to their chest
they are hedging their bets that if you
really knew you wouldn't love me
and so there's a gift there
done in a very gentle way not in a oh
i'm telling him come on in hey bill come
here you're not gonna believe this
that's the wrong way right
the right way saying
i don't keep secrets from dad i just
don't
but i also want to honor your trust
and i love you so here's what i'm going
to do i'm going to have to let him know
that you and i are having some difficult
challenging deep
conversations
i can either
tell him for you
or be with you i'll hold your hand while
you tell him or
i'm going to let him know that
you and i are talking about some hard
stuff
and that you're not ready to share it
with him but sometime you will be
willing to share it
okay
give her that choice
and um
she needs to know that she's not in
control of the house she's 13 that's too
much of a burden for a 13 year old to
carry
right even if she says you swore you
would never tell tell her i shouldn't
have done that i'm sorry
i shouldn't have done that i put too
much on you because you're carrying too
much in mom and dad's job is to help
carry stuff for you because you're 13.
um let her know that you're sorry you
shouldn't have said that if that's what
you did say and by the way parents never
tell your teenage kids that i promise i
won't tell never ever ever ever tell
them that that's an aside that was to
everybody else not to use her
and
do less and i'm not saying you are doing
this this is just every parent
whenever we get faced with these things
i don't know what to say when my kid
comes out and says they're bi and
they're 13 or they're 14 and i don't
know what to say when they say don't
tell dad you promise i don't know what
to say with these things i don't to say
my kid want to play basketball and
they're on the varsity team and now that
you want to quit i don't know what to
say that my kid doesn't believe in my
church anymore i don't know what to say
with these things
say less
and
sit closer
and say things like tell me more
what are you feeling where is that in
your body what are you nervous about
what are you excited about and lean more
towards
less words and less data
and more connection
okay and then when you get to the can i
instead of playing basketball i really
just want to go
out to the park and smoke weed with my
buddies you can say you don't have to
play basketball but you're not going to
go smoke weed but your buddies right you
boundaries come later but right now it's
about connection because my guess is
your daughter's still trying to figure
out who she is and what she is and she's
trying to find out what role she plays
in your house and most importantly she's
trying to find out
will y'all still love me and most
importantly what does love look like
does it look like cutting me off does it
look look like abandonment does it look
like you're gonna turn your back on me
does it look like you're gonna move out
what does it look like
and saying
i love you enough to a am i going to
hold i'm not going to let you carry this
by yourself because you're 12. you're
13. i love you enough to let you know i
don't keep secrets from my husband and
people who are married don't keep
secrets from one another
and i love you enough to let you know
this is your story to tell
and so when you're ready
you can be the one to tell that unless
you want me to do it for you
you're going to tell them it doesn't
have to be today
but you and i are going to keep talking
because i know you're working through
some stuff and i know you're thinking
about some things and trying to figure
out who you are like every 13 or 14 year
old on planet earth is
and exhale
sarah
she is lucky to have you as her mom
lucky to have you and by the way you're
gonna feel a great burden relieved when
you're not having to try to navigate a
13 year old's feelings because they can
be a lot and they don't always tell the
truth and by the way neither 20 year old
feelings or 35 year old feelings or 50
year old feelings or 75 year old
feelings our feelings are important and
they lie to us a lot